[Música]
por segundo año consecutivo la navidad
está marcada por la pandemia del cob y
19 en cerca de 4 mil vuelos de hoy y
mañana fueron cancelados en todo el
mundo varias aerolíneas suspendieron sus
viajes porque muchos de sus empleados
contrajeron el virus
la organización mundial de la salud
aprobó la primera vacuna contra el cob y
19 producida en américa latina' el aval
fue para las dosis de astrazéneca que se
desarrollan conjuntamente en méxico y
argentina analizaremos el tema en
minutos
el lugar donde los católicos dicen que
nació jesús está con pocos turistas esta
navidad a causa de la pandemia la ciudad
de belén en cisjordania fue afectada por
la prohibición de vuelos que impuso
israel para intentar frenar la variante
omicron tenemos reporte desde territorio
israelí
buenas noches y bienvenidos a las
noticias de france 24 yo soy maría clara
calle y estaré con ustedes
iniciamos con noticias de la variante
del coronavirus omicron en europa la
propagación de omicron disparó los
contagios además de atravesar una nueva
ola de la pandemia
varios países reportaron su máximo
histórico de casos diarios francia
rompió su propio récord con más de
94.000 positivos el ministerio de salud
recomendó adelantar la dosis de refuerzo
de 5 a 3 meses italia informó más de
50.000 nuevos contagios y por tercer día
consecutivo reino unido registró un
récord al confirmar cerca de 122 mil
nuevos contagios por su parte de
portugal también reportó la cifra más
alta de contagios desde enero
y cerca de 4.000 vuelos tuvieron que ser
cancelados hoy y mañana en gran medida
por el rápido avance de la variante
omicron según la empresa de
estadounidense flightaware especializada
en entregar datos en tiempo real sobre
vuelos las aerolíneas united airlines y
delta airlines por ejemplo suspendieron
docenas de sus vuelos de navidad porque
una parte de su personal contrajo
coronavirus de los viajes cancelados el
viernes
640 tenían como destino o punto de
partida eeuu
y la organización mundial de la salud
aprobó la vacuna contra el cob y 19 que
producen argentina y méxico se trata del
inmunizante que desarrollan los
laboratorios map science y liomont para
entender el alcance de esto conectamos
con el ansia pib médico especializado en
salud pública y director del centro
médico bienestar y salud en los ángeles
señor shapiro gracias por estar con
nosotros explíquenos que implica que la
ub se haya agregado a esta vacuna a su
lista de uso de emergencia
antes que nada muchas gracias
latinoamerica estaba ya luchando por
crear más de 20 tipos diferentes de
vacunas y es la primera realmente que
llega al punto de distribución teniendo
el nombre y la conducción justamente con
astrazéneca una gran posición para
latinoamérica para poder puede empezar a
protegerse una manera mucho más
eficiente de una manera regional esta
vacuna igual que otras vacunas de
astrazéneca utiliza un virus que
prácticamente lo disfruta lo disfruta
los disfrazamos justamente de kobe 19
para que nuestro cuerpo aprenda mucho
más cómo puedes defender contra el kobe
y explíquenos un poco cómo funciona esto
de producción conjunta de los
laboratorios de méxico y argentina y por
qué pueden producir la vacuna que ya
había desarrollado astrazéneca
definitivamente es una comuna en un
nuevo es una fórmula diferente y con
cosas locales lo utilizan justamente en
la parte primaria en méjico y lo
terminan en basando en argentina y de
esa manera nosotros podemos duplicar las
dosis y mucho más la repartición de
estas dosis que tanto necesitamos en
esta región es una de las cosas
importantísimas que nosotros estamos
teniendo y espero que sea la primera de
muchas más vacunas que latinoamérica
está produciendo y esta aprobación de la
organización mundial de la salud como
contribuye a combatir la pandemia en
américa latina'
desgraciadamente en este momento cuando
vemos que tenemos tan tantas dosis que
no están llegando a nuestra gente
nosotros estamos teniendo menos del 50%
de la población vacunada por lo menos
con una vacuna entonces eso deja tierra
fértil completamente para el cob y 19
sigue a brincar yo de una persona a otra
al momento que nosotros tenemos este
tipo de vacunas aumenta la posibilidad
de que nosotros defendamos de una manera
mucho más efectiva y local contra el
jove 19 señor shapiro muchas gracias por
toda esta información y nosotros
hablamos ahora también de otra noticia
de la pandemia porque ésta estaba
afectando el turismo en el lugar donde
los católicos afirman que nació jesús
pocas personas se reunieron en la plaza
del pesebre ubicada en la ciudad de
belén en cisjordania y es que israel
cerró sus fronteras desde donde llegaban
la mayoría de los turistas esto ante la
propagación de la variante omicron
y precisamente en israel nuestra
corresponsal mayas imirowicz nos cuenta
cómo se vive la navidad en un país donde
los cristianos no son la mayoría veamos
el reporte desde la ciudad de jaffa
en israel celebra la nochebuena apenas
un 2% de la población porque entre los 9
millones de israelíes hay sólo unos
200.000 cristianos la mayoría de ellos
árabes y rusos pero hay muchos judíos
israelíes que les gusta esta fiesta y si
bien no celebran ni la navidad ni la
noche buena y tal vez tampoco sepan
distinguir una de la otra dicen que les
gusta porque les hace sentirse un poco
en el extranjero gritas por eso en estas
fechas muchísimos israelíes se acercan a
la ciudad mixta de yafo aquí a este
árbol gigantesco de 15 metros que todas
las navidades se erige y se enciende
para celebrarlas y vienen estos
israelíes que como hace dos años apenas
pueden salir internacionalmente tal vez
vengan aquí a sentirse un poco en el
extranjero son varias las iniciativas
que se llevan a cabo en todo el mundo
para mantener vivo el espíritu navideño
y para continuar llevando la magia
especialmente a los menos favorecidos
andrés meza muñoz nos cuenta algunas de
ellas
después de dos años de ausencia por la
pandemia él está aquí en todas partes y
al mismo tiempo santa claus o papá noel
como se le conoce a este mítico
personaje dejó su tradicional trineo y
descendió en helicóptero sobre las
favelas de río de janeiro para
distribuir alimentos a las personas más
necesitadas el color de su piel generó
alegría entre los presentes hoy vi un
papá noel negro es lindo me representa a
mí representa a todos porque es muy raro
era un papá noel negro solo veo los
blancos estoy feliz se trata de una
iniciativa de una ong y cómo estás
cientos de visitas se llevaron a cabo en
todo brasil en vísperas de la navidad
para llegar a los lugares más
vulnerables
casi de manera simultánea a unos 5000
kilómetros al este del continente en la
capital de perú la legendaria
personalidad fue recibida con júbilo por
cientos de niños a los que entregó
dulces y juguetes desde 2005 julio
arrolló recauda donaciones para llevar
alegría a los más pequeños
es una alegría inmensa porque son niños
que valoran lo que tú entregas
ven que se acuerdan de ti
que siente en esta
que llega su superhéroe navideño en
europa papá noel llegó hasta hospitales
infantiles donde decenas de niños han
tenido que pasar la navidad internados
desde la ventana del equipo de rescate
alpino de italia saludo a los pequeños
en barcelona en españa' el espectáculo
estuvo protagonizado por integrantes del
cuerpo de bomberos y en rúsia un equipo
de rescatistas y bomberos descendió
desde el techo del edificio cubriendo
cada uno de los ventanales y es que
hasta los animales se metieron en el
papel de santa en tailandia una manada
de elefantes vestidos de rojo entregaron
con sus propias trompas mascarillas y
gel desinfectante a estudiantes de
escuelas primarias por segundo año
consecutivo las restricciones
implementadas para contener el cob y 19
han opacado gran parte de las
celebraciones
sin embargo iniciativas como estas han
demostrado que el espíritu navideño no
se ha visto afectado el papá francisco
celebró la misa de vigilia de navidad
desde la basílica de san pedro en ciudad
del vaticano y al igual que el año
anterior la pandemia redujo el aforo a
una quinta parte de los visitantes
usuales desde allí el pontífice pidió
que no haya
hacia los pobres
dios está no te viene a colmar la viñeta
dios viene esta noche a llenar de
dignidad la austeridad del trabajo nos
recuerda la importancia de otorgar
dignidad al hombre y a la mujer a través
del trabajo pero también de otorgar
dignidad al trabajo humano mismo ya que
el hombre es su amo y no su esclavo el
día de la vida repitamos no más muertes
en el lugar de trabajo y comprometámonos
a garantizarlo y en hong kong otras dos
esculturas que conmemoraban a las
víctimas de la masacre de tiananmen de
1989 fueron retiradas de otras
universidades de este territorio
semiautónomo de china el hecho se
produce después de que la escultura
conocida como el pilar de la vergüenza
para igualmente removida de la
universidad de hong kong
la justicia rusa multó a las grandes
empresas tecnológicas google y facebook
ahora bautizada como meta y las acusó de
una repetida falta de eliminación del
contenido considerado ilegal la sanción
estipula 95 millones de dólares contra
google y 27 millones contra facebook
para los críticos se trata de un intento
de las autoridades de ejercer un control
más estricto sobre internet algo que
dicen amenaza la libertad individual y
corporativa rusia ordenó a las empresas
que eliminen publicaciones que
promocionan el abuso de drogas y
pasatiempos peligrosos información sobre
armas y explosivos caseros así como las
de grupos que designe como extremistas o
terroristas
y hasta aquí las noticias ustedes sigan
conectados a la señal de france 24
[Música]